it is 4 a.m. Gaza time 9:00 p.m. on the
East Coast 6:00 p.m. on the west coast
where Joe Biden now in Washington is
likely sleeping after another long
weekend at the beach but it wasn't just
any regular weekend off for Joe Biden
according to reports he's now worried
sick that apparently we are on the verge
of a much broader conflict in the Middle
East and he has good reason to worry as
we speak the all powerful USS Gerald R
Ford aircraft carrier strike group is
now position position just off the coast
of Israel another carrier strike uh
group the USS Eisenhower that is
steaming through the Persian Gulf to
assist American troops in Iraq and Syria
who have been under constant attack from
Iranian proxies shocker once again for
the past two weeks meanwhile US military
advisers they are now on the ground they
are in Israel tonight this also includes
a three star general from the Marine
Corps the British royal Navy is also
deploying ships to the region and there
are reportedly now six Chinese warships
in the area yeah things are escalating
this is a very troubling situation to
say the least if America wants to avoid
a global war we will need clear
determined leadership moral Clarity
something we are not getting from Joe
Biden and his administration instead we
are getting stall tactics we're getting
confusion and mixed messages on his way
to the beach on Friday Biden seemingly
told Israel to delay its Invasion take a
look Israel remain ground invasion you
can get
out now a short time later the White
House walked back that statement and
said that Biden misheard the question
but then again today Biden seemed to
once again double down floating a
ceasefire if American hostages are
returned take a look is the US
supporting the hostages for ceasefire
deal why did you
we should have a ceasefire not ceas we
should
have we now could you imagine if a world
leader floated a ceasefire two weeks
after
91101 Israel has every right and frankly
an obligation to defend their people
eliminate Hamas prevent Gaza from being
a launching pad of tens and tens and
tens of thousands of rockets into Israel
the same thing by the way with Lebanon
to the north and Hezbollah but Joe Biden
he's been playing both sides my sources
in Israel they have been very clear he's
saying one thing publicly and something
else very differently behind the scenes
he says Israel has a right to
self-defense but is reportedly
attempting to stall the ground Invasion
into Gaza he's sending military advisors
to Israel and $100 million to the
Palestinians which we know will end up
in the hands of Hamas the terrorist
organization so tonight Biden is not
just literally waffling because of his
inherent weakness but also because of
his internal strife inside his own party
and inside that crazy brain of his and
by the way that's Democrats including
members of Congress are supporting
terrorist groups whose stated goal and
platform is the destruction of Israel
and meanwhile their friends in the media
mob they are all too happy to vilify
Israel with Hamas straight out
propaganda and today well give some
credit to the New York Times they admit
that they quote relied too heavily on
claims by Hamas following a blast in a
parking lot it never hit the hospital in
Gaza caused by a misfire from that's
right another Iranian back terror group
the Islamic Jihad now this is the same
New York Times now publishing articles
about the conflict in Gaza from what uh
an anti-semitic so-called journalist
with a history of praising Hitler and
the Nazis okay now sadly the New York
Times is not
the only Hamas sympathizer in the
American Press Reuters fake news CNN the
Associated Press all publish Hamas
propaganda as fact the AP which is a
disgraceful far-left organization they
won't even let their reporters refer to
Hamas as a terror group and apparently
the AP thinks that beheading kids raping
young women torturing Grandma killing
innocent young kids at a concert taking
hostages that's just part of the quote
resistance and on cable news forget it
it's worse than ever according to
reports msdnc they had temporarily
pulled three of their Muslim anchors off
the air last week because of an apparent
anti uh because of apparent
anti-Semitism concerns but as
mediaite.com reports one of them is
quote back on the air and quote as
anti-israel as ever last week we had
Medi Hassan I don't even know this guy
appeared on an MSNBC show where he
literally compared Israel to Russia
while giving Hamas the terror group a
free pass luckily it was a show that
very few people have ever watched hosted
by some guy named I don't know Chris
Christy Christopher somebody Hayes I
doubt many of you have ever heard of
this person another msdnc liar
conspiracy theorist as usual can you
imagine rooting for Hamas just two weeks
after they murdered 14 innocent citizens
and if you take out the population and
disolated out that would be the
equivalent of 38,000 plus Americans
being killed in a single day and tonight
virtually no one on the left is ready or
willing or capable of telling the truth
about this conflict Hamas is very
popular among Palestinians living inside
of Gaza but it receives the bulk of the
funding and organization from Iran
including the military planning
including the rockets and so do similar
Terror groups in Yemen Iraq and Syria
and Lebanon where Hezbollah is launching
a near constant stream of rockets into
Israel I've been there I've been on the
Gaza border I've been to the
neighborhoods what they call a kabut
where Rockets had hit one town in
particular 10,000 of them in a period of
10 years so I would say Gaza can no
longer be that launching pad that has to
be one of the military goals of Israel
at this time and unlike uh Joe Biden
well the prime minister of Israel
Benjamin Netanyahu is very clear about
what what what must be done to defend
his country he has moral Clarity
something missing with most American
leaders today take a
look if hisbah goes to war with Israel
it will make the mistake of its life we
will it with a force it cannot
even imagine and the consequences for it
and the Lebanese state will be
devastating Israel must do whatever it
takes to ensure its existence and
protecting its citizens mer including
taking off the head of the snake now for
far too long the mullers of Iran number
one state sponsors of Terror they have
enjoyed relative safety and comfort
while they seow chaos murder Terror
violence all throughout the world but
those days could soon be numbered hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere where
else